hello i am guillermo del toro and i'm
breaking down a scene from my new film
nightmare alley
the characters on nightmare alley are
seeking and confronting with characters
that challenge them or they push them to
find the truth and lilith has an office
that stan goes to seeking to know more
about her and seemingly wanting to use
her when in reality he will be used
[Music]
[Music]
mr carla
come in we start the scene with what i
call the hinge the hinge is a shot i use
in a lot of my movies and starts in a
smaller space which is the preamble
office the reception office from lillith
and then the camera
goes with the character and the doors
slide open and you reveal the entire
office which is a spectacular alley like
office because all the offices and the
places in the city are built like an
alley in the movie and you see the
office representing the character of
lilith it's beautiful but it conceals a
lot of things we will reveal in this
scene and other scenes that the office
is full of secret doors
and behind them there are recorders uh
safe
uh a secret entrance
so it's like lilith perfect but
concealing a lot of things
slow
day
have you not heard
we're at war
i'm aware
precisely the line is meant to signify
yes america is at war now but he is also
signified it needs to signify we you and
i
stan and lilith are at war haven't you
heard because he
humiliated her horribly in front of
everyone just in the scene before with
them
and now it's all questions on the
beginning of the scene you see and the
beginning of the scene is how did you
know i was here and she doesn't answer
and uh the having you heard we're at war
and he says i'm aware you know and you
don't know if you're saying yeah i'm
aware that we're at war or i'm aware
that there's a war outside
and and and then
she tries to humiliate him here and
there or she says do you think do you
think you have something big enough or
interesting enough for me
you know
and and and there's a constant change of
who is dominant to who
how did you know it was me
what brings you here you left me your
card didn't you we very carefully
patterned the walls the woodwork in the
walls after a psychological test her
office is in perfect order but you feel
a little bit of a menace and an elevated
position is an office that makes you
feel a little bit like
like a bumpkin you know there's a
superiority
to it what i do is i create environments
that allow the characters to thrive like
when you you create a terrarium
for the character to thrive and you can
see lilith moving
around the office in an elegant
extremely calculated way but in the
middle of the scene there is a small
break in which you see
her feelings are hurt or she's thinking
about things so
here we are
oh not me i never dreamed
the main part of the scene takes place
in a single shot this single shot starts
with her
reacting to stan saying you're not that
hard to read lady and it follows all the
way to almost the ending of the scene
and we have lilith come towards the
camera move away from the camera a close
a two shot becomes a close-up a close-up
becomes a wide it's a an orchestrated
shot
that you don't want to break because
when the scene starts is a duel of two
opposing sides so you cut to one side
and then you cut to the other but once
they engage when they once they are face
to face you don't want to break the
tension
between the two actors and you preserve
it in a single shot and then as it
progresses
if you are observant
you start noticing that lilith wants to
leave no trace of anything she uses the
fire which will be used in the movie a
few times the fire as transition she
uses the fire to destroy the evidence
and so forth and it's a scene that is
part of the no there's a number of
scenes with lilith and stan
that are like little theatrical plays
almost in which you have scenes that
last
as long as the encounter lasted there
are three four five-minute scenes that
describe
a period of time exactly of the same
length between the characters
microphones that's right
fire recorder
you recording this
no the center of the scene was comprised
of a single shot we had to make sense of
why they would move here or there for
example after being offended i said to
kid you're gonna go get his hat
because you want him out of there and
then as you manipulate the hat and he's
talking you go ah
maybe i can maybe i can destroy him this
other way you know and for stan
emotionally wanted to mix a guy that
feels superior to her and a guy that
knows he is inferior to her and is
absolutely
almost like as a young child in all of
this woman
you know and
for uh for kate
we talked about
using
the complete elegance of lilith and
punctuated with little breaks
in which you see the emotion one of the
things we did is uh
the change of scales the chains of
statures
is something very important
lilith is down stan is on top
looking down on her then she gets up and
now she's she seems formidable we use it
twice in the movie she seems larger than
stan
and then
he she leaves him behind and then
it's a dance it's like a waltz of coming
closer and further apart above and below
and so forth my office is wired to
record all analysis sessions
you got a smoother line but you run a
rack same as me is that what this is
it's very interesting this because uh
when william lindsey gresham wrote the
novel you know he was absolutely in a
time in which
uh psychoanalysis traveled to america
later than europe so a psychoanalysis
was landing in america and it was seen
for a long time as a another piece of
hawks terrorism
something that didn't have a real
credence or sounded a little too kooky
for the common sense american way of
life
and it was landing at the same time
taking over from what had been defined
in the turn of the century as
spiritualism
and spiritual revival and and sort of
tent
uh
preaching hogs tourism so there's a
clash between these things
and uh urban sophistication
and uh this enchantment with the with
the loss of all the pastoral
foundational myths of america is a very
interesting moment and a part of
the charm of the novel
with gresham is that he uses the tarot
to hint at real supernatural depths
or the possibility of something larger
than humans
being under pressure there and then he
very wisely uses psychology to say
what young carl jung said once he said
if we don't do the subconscious
conscious and change it we'll keep doing
the same things and call it destiny and
i think that's pretty much the thesis of
the movie
if you displease the right people the
world closes in on you very very fast
[Music]
you